was ist dein tipp an unserer landsleute
alle besser zu hause bleiben
die monate auch noch irgendwie versuchen
ist selber lachen bei zu hause bleiben
schöne holland fahren aber deutschland
bleibt zu hause
[Musik]
freunde ich habe einen geheimtipp
bekommen in einem vorort von nrw namens
holland soll unbeschwertes leben wieder
möglich sein
ich der reporter ohne grenzen decke auf
die niederlande haben wieder geöffnet
auch für deutsche touristen aber ich
meine es sind nicht so viele da sind
gekommen
wie schön ist es dass hier ein roller
wieder alles auf wahnsinn wirklich
neu ist schon schön dass skala von eins
bis zehn wie voll ist es hier
11 wir drehen zu hause alle durch
wie sehr freuen sie sich dass die
deutschen auch wieder da sind ich kann
dir nicht sagen wie glücklich dass mir
das mag
also wenn man als niederländer kein bock
auf deutschland sollte man dieses
wochenende nach nordrhein westfalen
fahren
das wahrscheinlich besser weil 80
prozent zurück ich werde vielleicht muss
durch und augen bücher anders denkt wird
es schrecklich aber wenn wir so weiter
gehen habe begleichen irgendwo mehr eine
stadt nirgendwo mehr eine kneipe oder
ein schönes gemütliches bistros erst mal
hallo frau donders sie sind die
bürgermeisterin von roermond und seit
neuestem dürfen deutsche wieder bis zu
30 kilometer in die niederlande
einreisen
deswegen erst mal prost kosten ob sie
tun was notwendig ist um nicht weiter
ansteigen aufsteigen gezogen zu haben
das können wir einfach nicht unsere
krankenhäuser haben wir viel zu viel
sorge aber frisch gezapftes bier
sie haben sie jetzt nicht gerettet wie
ich habe von dem city niederländer
gerade genervt von der regierung oder
von den deutschen ich kann das nicht
verstehen hat gibt viel lärm machen
hier ist das pure leben halt um mich
herum dass das ist ja das schöne aber
das gut ist das virus ist ja erst 30
kilometern hinter der grenze
da fängt das erst an also hier sind wir
eigentlich safe das haben sie für den
eindruck benehmen sich die deutschen gut
ich denke schon ja ja da hast du denn
angst vor krone also eigentlich nur
selber habe zumindest die maske lieber
tanja huber ich noch notfall simon
serverlast pfalz corona kommt hast du
sie immer griffbereit ja genau
ganz schnell aufziehen dann zugesichert
viele deutsche kommen ja jetzt hierhin
um bier zu trinken auch und free zu
essen und zu essen ja kaum fried und aus
besser zugehört und indirekt osten
zahlen liegen ich frage jetzt nochmal
denn sie sich mal vor ich bin vom
holländischen fern sind wie benehmen
sich die deutschen ja ja ich denke dass
deutsche western deutschland bleiben
können und holländer in holland kennen
das ist eigentlich nicht gut dass sie
hier sind teilweise die leute stehen
einen geschäften an da ist überhaupt
nicht mal einen meter abstand ja schon
gewagt teilweise was ist dein tipp an
unsere landsleute alle besser zu hause
bleiben
die monate auch noch irgendwie versuchen
es selber noch mal zu hause bleiben
schöne holland fahren aber in
deutschland bleibt zu hause kommen sie
in der zivilen camping des kba
da ist es gut leben da ist kein corona
und freiheit heute kommen wir noch mal
krachen lassen
die nächsten wochen auf der
intensivstation werden hart genug
beginnt soll das ist kein problem zügig
aber für mich bleibt zu hause bleibt
es ist besser das virus ist nicht weg
auch wenn er auch wenn die leute denken
oder wenn es aussieht ist nicht weg es
ist nicht weg lotte bleibt zu hause wie
sie aber genauso kommen geben frikandel
erst perfekt holland das ist ganz nach
meinem geschmack
und falls ich mir doch was eingefangen
haben sollte und in quarantäne muss
freunde
ich hab vor besorgt
[Musik]
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
info box neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]